now people on variable mortgages are
facing the prospect of paying
potentially hundreds of pounds more each
month if interest rates are to rise
further to combat sorry inflation as is
widely expected those trying to get a
mortgage are also likely to suffer as
lenders have started pulling their best
fixed-rate deals after the pound fell to
its lowest level against the dollar
following the government's announcements
of tax cuts followed by borrowing so
what steps should homeowners those
trying to get on the housing ladder and
also renters be taking well here to
answer your questions are Laura Suter
who's head of personal finance at the
investment platform AJ Bell and also
Mark Savile an independent mortgage
advisor a trusted Finance advice I thank
you both so much for joining us we've
had quite a lot of people getting in
touch with with their questions
um a lot of them about mortgages
obviously and some about savings and
personal finance as well and Mark maybe
come to you first because I've got a
couple of very specific ones about about
mortgages
Mike has been in touch he says we
already have an agreed mortgage offer
and I'm hoping to complete in the next
month or two will the bank be able to
withdraw this or do they have to honor
the mortgage offer
and that's a very very good question
that Mike has actually raised
um the lenders have all said that the
mortgage offers that they've issued so
far will be on it I haven't seen any
lender say anything different to that I
would sincerely hope that that wouldn't
change
um I have actually been asked that very
question this morning by some clients of
mine already and I've been able to
assure them that the lenders are all
saying so far yes we are going to honor
mortgages that we've already offered oh
so that that kind of links into another
one uh Dom has been in touch he's got a
mortgage deal agreed so it's not a new
mortgage but it's a deal that's been
agreed that kicks in when his current
mortgage ends in December equally should
he not be worried that the bank had
withdraw it if it has been an agreed
offer
I mean technically the banks are free to
to decide if they want to withdraw
mortgages they tend not to want to do
that because it's not good publicity for
them at all
um definitely go and speak to your
mortgage broker and get your mortgage
broker to speak to the lender and make
sure that that lender is intending to
offer those deals that have already been
agreed but as I say the ones that I've
looked at so far when clients who are
worried have actually approached me the
lenders have all been saying yes we're
going to be offering the offers that
we've already committed to okay so
that's quite positive so it seems that
if you have a a deal that's agreed you
should be okay but it's worth just going
back and checking belts and braces
um would always check yeah Laura let's
bring in you now um a more general
question from Tom
um he says is now the right time to be
selling your house I mean it all seemed
the market does seem to be
quite fluctuating at the moment doesn't
it but but does this mean that it's a
good time if you're thinking of selling
I mean it's always quite stressful
selling a house or buying a property and
that feels even more so at the moment I
think there's a lot of nervousness about
what the housing Market's going to do
and people buying or selling now are
worried about whether they're selling
for the right price so I but I think the
advice is that it's kind of impossible
to time the market even the experts
don't manage to do it correctly all of
the time and so rather than trying to
get your crystal ball out I think you
need to think about wider circumstances
why are you selling is that the right
move for you
um and proceed with the if it is I think
if you're trying to time the market
exactly to to sell at the peak um then
you're probably not going to be too
successful in doing that it is there are
so many different circumstances out
there that come into it when people
think about selling that and another one
then perhaps for you Laura this is from
Elaine and she says should I use my
savings to pay off my mortgage or sit
tight and wait to see what happens with
interest rates now next year
this is such an interesting one and it's
actually one I think a lot of people are
going to be thinking about when mortgage
rates were rock bottom and pretty low it
didn't necessarily make sense to use
that saving some people would have
preferred to invest it and maybe got a
better return or just have it to one
side but if we're looking at the
prospect of mortgage rates I mean
they've already risen considerably and
Rising further from here at the same
time while savings rates have risen
you're not getting a kind of
inflation-beating return or anywhere
near it on your savings so at that point
that might tip the balance and make it
look much more attractive to use some of
that savings if you've got it to either
pay down some of your Mortgage Debt or
all of it um and I think people that
have got a fixed rate that's coming up
in a year or two's time that are worried
about perhaps being able to afford their
mortgage if rates do rise a lot it's
worth thinking about whether you want to
overpay by a little bit each month if
you can afford to
um to help try and eat away that
Mortgage Debt so that when you do come
to remortgage the debt isn't quite so
high even if the interest rates are
higher that's an interesting point isn't
it Mark is that something you would
recommend I mean would you say that now
is a good time to be paying down your
mortgage if you're in that glorious
financial situation of being actually
able to do that when most people are
just worried about actually meeting the
payments as it is
I'm sure everyone would love to be in a
position where they could pay more
um we always have the conversation with
our clients about making overpayments on
the mortgage
um it in the end it means that you will
pay less interest and for many of our
clients it enables them to actually look
at shortening the mortgage term which is
for most people exactly what they want
to do
um if you're looking at making an
overpayment
um then at least you then are going to
benefit from a lower debt when you do
come to remortgage in the future so yeah
we'd always recommend people to look at
whether they should make overpayments on
their mortgage if they've got the funds
to do it
um
um
Laura back to you a question from David
uh you were just talking about about the
banks passing on interest rates for
Savers well of course that doesn't seem
to happen quite as quickly as the rates
go up for mortgages does it uh David
says we hear a lot about the base rate
rising and the high effect that this has
our mortgage rates but when will we see
the bank's savings rates rise and will
it be proportional
so we've already seen quite a lot of
banks and building societies increase
their interest rates but I think what
David's probably referring to is the
money that he's got sitting in a savings
account or a current account isn't
earning any more than it was last year
and that's because to benefit from
rising interest rates you've really got
to switch bank accounts it's a much
quicker process than it was before but
generally if your money's been in an
account
um or you're with one of the big High
Street Banks and it's been an account
for a year or more you're not going to
be getting the best rate that you could
it's kind of those newcomer or
Challenger Banks out there that really
want your money and are offering you
higher interest rates on your savings in
return so if you've got money that's
sitting there that's not earning that
much then you need to switch it at the
moment
um the best easy access savings account
so one that you can take money out of
whenever you want to is paying about two
percent just over like two percent Mark
so if you're not getting that on your
savings at the moment then you should
look to switch but unfortunately the way
Banks work they don't just top up our
savings accounts with better interest as
and when the base rate Rises you kind of
have to hunt out those better deals
which is a bit frustrating because as
you point out on the kind of mortgage
and debt side they automatically raise
those rates and in terms of of switching
you know people who who may have savings
how relatively easy is it to do that
Laura so much easier than in the past
um previously you had to fill out a lot
of paperwork often send off forms and
proof of ID for example now a lot of
these Challenger Banks and smaller Banks
a lot of them are kind of app only on
your phone and I sent one up the other
week and it took me less than five
minutes to set up the account it's okay
so filling in a few forms
um often you have to kind of send a
picture or a video of yourself so you
can prove you are who you say you are
um but it's really very easy and then of
course transferring money between
accounts is so much easier now so for
people that do have savings and want to
get a better return on their money they
might find that in return for that five
minutes of hassle or even if it takes 10
minutes of hassle setting up a new
account and transferring their money
actually the additional return they're
going to get could be pretty decent and
make that 10 minutes worthwhile yeah it
really could couldn't do it
um Mark we've had a question from Amir
and this is about mortgages again pain
and these these are the people of course
who are now thinking about what's
happening now and looking to next year
when perhaps their mortgage deals are
due to end so they're not in a position
where they can talk to the banks yet so
what are their options if if they are
due to remortgage say next spring and
they're they're sort of looking at this
with a head in their hands
that's a very very good question from
Amir
um and a number of people are going to
look at what they're going to do with
their mortgages next year I'm one of
them I've got a mortgage rolling off
next year so I'm also going to be having
that same conversation with myself
um what I would do is go back to your
mortgage broker and I would have the
conversation about what your options are
should you actually wait for the
mortgage deal to roll off next year and
see what interest rates are then should
you look at actually taking a new
product now if you did what sort of
project product should you look to be
taking it's very much a conversation of
questions and answers and answers and
questions to be going to and through the
mortgage advisor and the client based
upon which the mortgage advisor should
then come back to you and say well based
on what the conversations are that we've
had and your circumstances I'm going to
give you a recommendation which is and
then you should you should have some
clear advice about what what you could
do but definitely a conversation to have
or start having now don't just wait for
the next year if you're worried and and
Laura and you know obviously we you're a
personal finance expert Mark is a
mortgage advisor there will be people
who
don't use either of your services a lot
of people might think it costs a lot of
money to go and get financial advice I
don't have you know the spare money it's
going to cost me I'm just going to do it
myself
um would you say by and large in terms
of what it costs to get the kind of
advice that you you are able to offer
it's worth people doing or those on a
real budget how can they get this advice
free
so I think um there's probably two
things there I would say with something
major like your mortgage that can have
um a massive impact and you're obviously
signing up to a very long-term product
and with the market being as complicated
as it is at the moment I would say using
a mortgage broker would be a better idea
at the moment maybe if you've kind of
gone it alone previously and been okay
with that um you might want to
reconsider this time around now I say
that I'm not a mortgage broker I have um
nothing to gain from saying that I just
think even myself I would use a broker
in this current market because
everything is moving so quickly there
are so many different variables you're
trying to guess what interest rates are
going to do and for some people using a
broker and them finding you a slightly
better deal or working out a way to make
your mortgage more affordable might
really help you out in the in the longer
term and over the term of that mortgage
but to your other point if we kind of
move away from mortgages and think more
broadly about wider personal finances so
things like savings and investing
there's so many resources out there now
for people who want to do it themselves
um and want to go alone and don't want
to pay a professional and um and I think
that's that's fine you can go out and do
your research obviously like anything if
you're doing it yourself it's going to
take longer and it's going to be um more
work on your part and you're going to
have to kind of um navigate that system
but um It's Perfectly doable and and
there's so much help and resource out
there particularly at the moment because
everyone is focused on making the most
from their finances because everything
is so expensive at the moment indeed and
I suppose Mark the that what you would
would say Obviously you would say is
worth going to a mortgage advisor but
because the the cost that the mortgage
advisor might cost you you could maybe
save over the course of your mortgage
and I think if I was if I was looking
for a mortgage at the moment in a
mortgage Market which is definitely
going through some turmoil I would want
to have the comfort of knowing that
someone was giving me an advice and a
recommendation not just on what the
internet might be telling me to do I
think I would be very very cautious in
in this market and I would want to go
and get some quality advice to know that
I'm making the right decision
um I certainly would feel more
comfortable doing it that way
um not all advisors charge it's up to
the individual company what they would
charge you can find an independent
advising use something like unbiased
um so it's it's it there are resources
out there to help you locate somebody
and yes if you want to do something
direct with the lens you're perfectly
free to do that the lenders do have
direct channels which they will take
Direct business well let's return to our
two guests who are answering your
questions about mortgages about personal
finance in light of what happened on
Friday a lot of you've got lots and lots
of questions and Lucy let's return Laura
sorry let's return to you first of all
um Silva has been in touch now he says
I'm already struggling to pay for the
increase in mortgage payments if the
rates increase again is there any help
for people like me I mean is there
anything like that is there any funds
can you go to the government and say I I
used to build for my mortgage but I
can't now what happens
so I would assume in this circumstance
that they're on a variable rate mortgage
which means that your interest rate goes
up as the bank of England base rate goes
up and those people have obviously seen
quite big hikes this year as the base
rate has gone up
um I think the first thing to say is
that you should speak to your mortgage
provider if you're in this situation I
think lots of people think um if they're
struggling to pay their bills that they
don't want to speak to their mortgage
provider and it's better to kind of try
and make those payments um on their own
but mortgage providers are very aware
that lots of people are struggling at
the moment they've been told by the
regulator to help out customers and they
have schemes in place to help people so
I think your best passport of call is to
go to them and talk about potential
Solutions there might be that might be
things like having a mortgage holiday
where you don't make your payments for a
short time or changing the type of
mortgage you're on to reduce your
payments or potentially extending the
term of your mortgage which reduces your
monthly payments
um I would then say as a kind of second
Port of Call
um anyone in this situation should speak
to someone like systems advice who can
look at your finances overall and they
can work out things like whether you
might be entitled to any benefits or any
local Council support or government
support or whether there's anything
um any kind of tax breaks you could make
use of that you're not currently and
that will might help boost your income
so that you are more able to make those
monthly payments but I think their main
message is
um it's very easy to kind of bury your
head in the sand and think that you'll
worry about it later but we know that
costs are only increasing this winter
and so if you're already in this
situation it's definitely better to
tackle it head on now even if that seems
quite a scary Prospect and Mark just
talking about lenders with with mortgage
holidays are they pretty Universal now
or is it just a very small number of
lenders that do that
well well Laura's actually said is very
true the lenders have actually been
tasked by the regulator for making sure
that they do look at all the options for
customers who approach them I would
totally Echo what Laura's just said
about engaging with your mortgage lender
to see what they can actually offer you
in terms of help
um I would certainly look at things like
citizens advice again independent
organization to help people who feel
their own difficulty
um do go back to your mortgage broker
and have the conversation if you are on
a variable rate mortgage it may be there
is potential for you to go into a fixed
rate mortgage so that you could actually
at least know what your budget is well
actually it's a conversation to go and
have yeah well that's one of the
questions that we've had Glenn got in
touch he said is it worth considering
changing to a fixed rate mortgage
bearing in mind the anticipated rise of
interest rates I mean if you're on a
variable rate if you're on a Tracker
Mark how easy is it to go back to your
bank and say right I want to switch
go back to your bank go back to your
mortgage advisor have the conversation
about the deal that you're on what your
mortgage advisor will do is they'll look
at what um the product you want now
they'll look at any early repayment
charges as that you could potentially be
liable for
um they'll look at the products
available and they'll have a
conversation with you and make an
analysis of your own circumstances with
a view to recommending the right thing
for you because what what may be right
for you may not be right for somebody
else it's very much a one-on-one
conversation to go and have definitely
and let's maybe widen out a little bit
Laura we've been talking a lot about
mortgages and people with mortgages but
of course so many people are renting and
a lot of those uh people that they're
renting from will have buy to let
mortgages they will also go up is the
general thought that this is gonna mean
that rents are going to go up as well or
do we expect that landlords are going to
swallow the difference
um I think we're expecting rents to go
up as well we've seen rents already rise
this year and I think if you're about to
let landlord who's seeing their costs
dramatically increase
um most likely you're going to pass that
on in increased rent even if you're not
increasing your buyers as much as your
mortgage has increased by so I think
renters are going to feel the the pain
of this as those kind of rates trickle
down I think the only people that are
going to be immune from this are people
that own their property and don't have a
mortgage which obviously doesn't
represent that many people out there
um Mark you obviously look at the
housing market the whole time James got
in touch with the question he says is
this likely to cause the housing market
to crash and house prices to drop
gosh um I have absolutely no idea what
the housing market is going to do I have
no idea what house prices are going to
do over the longer term
um nobody nobody can answer these
questions at the moment because really
we've had an announcement from the bank
of England they were going to raise
rates on um last week to 2.25 that's
where we are today lenders are repricing
their offerings
um nobody knows where this is going so
forecasting anything to do with the
housing market would would be no more
than fortune telling at this moment in
time Laura what about your crystal ball
um we've got a question from Josh on a
similar subject he says I'm in the
process of buying my first property in
view of recent events should I look to
pull out and wait until the market
settles down
gosh I really feel for Josh I think I'm
buying your first property is so
nerve-wracking and then doing it at a
time when there's headlines filled with
the prospect of a housing crash and
worrying about the fact that you might
be buying at the peak
um I think this is uh like Mark said an
impossible question to answer because we
just don't know what housing Market's
going to do and if I did I'd be a much
richer person I think if we talk through
some of the logic I think some people
are expecting that if interest rates
Rise by this much then um not as many
people are going to be able to get
mortgages some people are going to
struggle to afford their mortgages and
those homes will be repossessed and that
in turn will dampen demand in the
housing market
um I think that's the logic at the
moment that's leading to those headlines
and and those worries about a house
price crash
um but like Mark points out there are so
many uncertain things we've um we've got
a new king we've just got a new prime
minister we've just got a brand new
budget and another update coming in
November the markets are very jittery
that's the Assumption at this point in
time but if we think how different
things were a week or two weeks ago
um then in a month's time the situation
might be very different which is a very
long-winded way of just echoing what
Mark said which is it's impossible to
predict but I completely feel for Josh
and I and I can't say what I would do in
that situation I think you've just got
to think about how long you're planning
to buy that property for whether you're
buying it just to make a profit or
whether you're buying it because you
want to stop renting and you want to own
a home of your own and think about some
of your motivations of of why you're
doing that I think
um also just to add if you're a
first-time buyer and you're buying with
a very small deposit and you're buying
um you're looking in a mortgage now and
you're worried about kind of if you're
borrowing at your maximum affordability
and you're worried about being able to
afford that if rates go up then that is
another factor to consider kind of
modeling how you might be able to afford
that mortgage if if house prices dropped
a bit and and if mortgage rates went up
okay it's a lot to think of at Laura
seta ahead of personal finance at AJ
Bell and Mark Savile independent
mortgage advisor at trusted Financial
advice thank you both so much it seems
your main advice is Keep Calm try not to
panic and get some proper advice if you
can possibly afford it or do a lot of
research great thanks so much both of
you